so imagine this 47 of the population on
the planet today is living in
electricity poverty but this Biden
Administration is the most
anti-hydrocarbon Administration in
American history and all and there it
seems like this climate issue is the
only thing they want to talk about why
isn't he pounding the damn Podium saying
we have to do something about this
instead he's standing up and bragging
about some stupid 900 million dollar
loan to the angle and so they can build
solar panels where are your priorities
where is your humanism
[Music]
hello everyone watching and listening
today I'm speaking with author podcaster
and film producer Robert price
we discussed topics from his latest book
a question of power electricity and The
Wealth of Nations their current Audacity
Of Those pushing the zero emissions Net
Zero agenda how those policies really
affect the developing world and the poor
in the west hint it's not good
the feasibility and necessity of coal
and fossil fuel and nuclear power now
and into the foreseeable future the
catastrophic practical and environmental
problems related to wind and solar and a
positive vision for the future we could
all share voluntarily should our
institutions finally drop their
fear-mongering tyranny-inducing doomsday
narrative let's start well we can start
wherever you want but perhaps on the
renewable energy front might be a good
place to dive in sure and uh so well I'm
glad to talk about all those I mean
those are all I'm passionate about those
issues those are my purpose and so uh
also just point out on my latest sub
stack uh I don't know if your team sent
it to you but the title was let them eat
solar panels and the uh gist of it is
that the U.S export import Bank just
funded a 900 million dollar loan for a
solar project in Angola Jordan 60 of the
people in Angola don't even have
electricity why in the name of Jesus
Mary and Joseph were we running a solar
project they hit a natural gas powered
plant and instead we're funding solar
and the XM Banks uh press release said
to help Angola meet its climate
commitment
yeah well you can you can be absolutely
certain that the primary concern of the
angolans is to meet their bloody climate
commitment right no so it's so
interesting watching the leftists in
particular on the environmental front
um Rampage down this pathway because
they're the same ideologues who
constantly
um what conspire to accuse conservatives
and classic liberals of being
colonialists in their Endeavors and I've
never seen a more colonialist Endeavor
in my entire life than the attempt to
impose climate concerns on the
developing world it is something bloody
miraculous to see it and to see the
leftists sacrifice the poor to their
idiot planetary concerns is is an
absolutely it's an absolute bloody
nightmare as far as I'm concerned so in
this situation in Angola sounds like
it's tailor-made for that kind of idiocy
so what how is it the case that uh solar
power plant can become the number one
concern on the International Development
front for Angola like how good how did
we get there
well how long do we have Jordan uh it's
a long history
um but this has been something that's
been ongoing now for years where the
World Bank and the other and
multilateral bilateral lending
institutions are refusing to fund any
hydrocarbon projects in developing
countries
um and this latest example is the
angolan story where and President Biden
bragged about it during a high dollar
fundraise he spoke at a high dollar
fundraiser for the league of
conservation voters uh in early June and
he bragged about this saying we're
building a huge solar plant in Angola
and the average sixty percent of the
people in Angola don't have electricity
at all and you're bragging about the in
the in the export import bank brags in
their press release about we're helping
Angola meet its climate commitments I
mean it's crazy town and and this is a
country that has an enormous natural gas
and oil uh wealth
um we should they should be allowed to
burn those hydrocarbons this is it's
it's green colonialism carbon
imperialism uh green colonialism there
are and numerous leaders numerous
analysts have pointed this out but I I
just find it anathema I mean electricity
is the key to better life for everyone
everywhere on the planet and this is
effectively telling the the developing
countries and one of the most
desperately poor countries in Africa no
you can't burn hydrocarbons
yeah yeah it's I I think it's I actually
think it's criminal it's criminal levels
of stupidity to do this to the
developing world and so so tell me Tell
let's let's go into your background a
bit so that everybody who's watching and
listening knows a little bit about you
so why don't you run through your
biography and tell us all about how long
you've been writing and how you've done
your investigations sure well first
things first I'm I'm a proud father
um I'm proudly married to the Lauren my
wife we've been married for 37 years uh
we have three great kids uh we're empty
nesters which is a beautiful thing uh
but we have three great kids married
Michael and Jacob and they're all
thriving
um I've been a journalist my whole
career I've never had a real job I've
been a reporter my whole life
um I wrote my first book on Enron which
came out in uh 2002 uh it's now already
20 years ago
um I started my career in newspapering
in the Austin at the Austin Chronicle
here in Austin uh in the late 80s
um that one thing led to another led me
into the book business in my book on
Enron is called pipe dreams greed ego
and the death of Enron uh came out now
20 and a half years ago and I'm still
writing about Enron in fact these days
um so now six books later my latest is a
question of power electricity and The
Wealth of Nations I've been very
fortunate to have uh the same publisher
public affairs the same editor Lisa
Kaufman uh same agent Dan Green all have
been incredibly supportive and helpful
along the way so I I consider myself
incredibly fortunate uh Jordan to be
able to write about think about do a lot
of public speaking on energy and power
these are the world's biggest industries
biggest and most important businesses
and particularly now where there are so
many political issues around all of
these things and so much focus on uh
climate and and Renewables and and and
and I think there are some positive
Trends and I want to talk about those
but uh I see a lot of bad policy
happening and particularly in Europe and
and here in the US where Europe has just
driven itself into the ditch but um yeah
that's my brain oh yeah and I mean the
rest of the world seems
um hell-bent on copying let's say
Germany which has had the most
catastrophic energy and environment
policies that you could possibly produce
short of shutting down the entire grid
not least because what their energy
prices are now five times what they
should be
they shut down their nuclear plants
their energy provision is now unreliable
they're they are dependent on Russia and
other totalitarian States for their
energy provision energy is so expensive
that electric car manufacturers are
moving from Germany to China Germany is
de-industrializing because the energy
prices are too high plus and this is the
kicker they're actually polluting more
per kilowatt than they were 15 years ago
because since they've shut down their
reasonable sources of electricity
including nuclear which they import
anyways from France they're now turning
to burning lignite for God's sake which
is the dirtiest form of coal
isn't it insane I mean you couldn't make
it up you just I'll give you one I'll
make you even one better so you
mentioned lignite and the company it's
rwe of memory serves right is the big
utility so they're expanding a lignite
mine so they can provide more lignite
which is a low rank coal emits more CO2
per kilowatt hour than any other form of
power generation and to expand the
lignite mine Jordan they took down a
wind project
oh yeah
yeah
the iron the irony is just remarkable
but to your point yes Germany has more
than any other country in Europe has
driven itself into the ditch they did it
to themselves and they're patting
themselves on the back I mean none of it
makes any sense
um yeah well it's it's the response
seems to be well we didn't do stupid
things fast enough
I like that so let's hurry up let's
drive ourselves faster into the ditch
um but yeah I mean the coup de gras was
them shutting down their last nuclear
plants when they knew they were were
short natural gas
um they knew they were you know we're no
longer going to be able to import as
much gas from Russia so what did they do
they went into the uh Global LNG market
and they've snapped up as many LNG
cargos and future contracts as they
could and in doing so what did they do
what well not only did they are they
burning more lignite more coal to your
point but they also priced out a lot of
developing a lot of developing countries
from importing liquefied natural gas
principally among them Pakistan which is
remarkable because Pakistan in February
announced we're done with the LNG
business we're going to burn we're going
to burn coal and so the pakistanis are
now saying we're going to expand our
coal-fired capacity so
um it's not just that this is affecting
Germany it's having knock-on effects in
the developing world well you know when
the German Chancellor came over to visit
our idiot country and he asked Trudeau
if there was any possibility of
increasingly liquid natural gas imports
from Canada and of course Trudeau has
done everything he can for the last 10
years to absolutely devastate the
Canadian oil and gas industry and to
make the export of liquid natural gas
impossible and so Trudeau said well we
can't make a business case for that
which is exactly the same bloody thing
that he said when the Japanese leader
came and asked for the same thing and
the reason that he can't make a business
case for it is because his government
has produced policies that have made the
export of Canadian fossil fuel resources
which are among the cleanest in the
world impossible and so so I like I
really don't understand how the hell
this can be happening in Germany I mean
I'm I'm not a cynic although you know
whatever naive optimism I had about the
political process has certainly been
disabused but everything that is
happening in in Germany is so stupid on
the energy front that it's a kind of
Miracle especially because you know you
could give the damn Devils their due if
they were able to say well we made
electricity five times as expensive but
we've cut emissions by a certain
proportion and here's the net
environmental benefit which all of which
I think is complete BS by the way but if
they could say that well that would be
something but for them to also have to
say oh well we've made electricity five
times more expensive and unreliable plus
we pollute more it's like there's zero
Victory that's F minus man you guys
failed on every bloody front including
the ones you set up as your own
principles and yet nothing seems to
happen and as you said you know Biden
can come out and and and and flourish
his agreement with Angola to produce a
kind of electricity they don't need at a
tremendously elevated price well
engaging in this neocolonial Enterprise
like I can't believe we can be this
stupid I can't understand how this could
happen so obviously Germany is this
classic example of what not to do what's
remarkable is what's happening here in
the United States where California is
following this example straight into the
ditch more than any other state in the
U.S California has emulated these
policies of of mandating Renewables of
shutting down base load power plants
they shut down the San onofre nuclear
plant um a few years ago they almost
succeeded in closing Diablo Canyon that
was Newsom made you know I think finally
sobered up and said no we need this
plant forget that it's nuclear it's nine
percent of our electric generation uh
production in California but look at
what has happened it's a similar story
Jordan for all of the effort and all the
money that the California has spent
they've seen no reduction in their
overall emissions from their from their
electric generation sector further they
have seen their electric prices rise
faster than any other state in the
United States since 2008 and I've
written about this on my sub stack
um Schwarzenegger signed a renewable
energy mandate in 2008 since then
California's electric rates had gone up
at a rate three times faster than that
of the average in the United States it's
unconscionable what they're doing Jordan
and this is in a state that is dominated
by the Democratic party the liberals who
say they care about the poor in the
middle class and yet this and this is
what as my late brother John Bryce said
just grills my cheese I mean the it's
it's ruinously regressive California has
the highest poverty rate in America
Jordan and yet they are sticking it to
the poor in the middle class in a big
way and where the the peak electric
rates in California now 40 50 cents a
kilowatt hour I mean this is fine if you
live in a nice house that's on San
Francisco Bay but the the low-income
people don't live there they can't
afford to live there they live inland
where they have to use air conditioning
so all of this climate I I have to say
it very clearly nearly all of this
climate policy whether it's mandates for
electric cars or the renewable mandates
rooftop solar it's it's ruined
especially regressive it screws the poor
in the middle class I've been absolutely
stunned to watch the left
in their Rampage to sacrifice the poor
to to fail to save the planet you know
it's almost as
unconscionable to me as the fact that
the left again climbed in bed with the
pharmaceutical companies so radically on
the on the uh on the pandemic front you
know I mean there's lots of things to be
said in relationship to the so-called
pandemic which I also don't believe in
by the way because I think it was a
pandemic of totalitarian overreaction
and not uh pandemic of illness but the
fact that the left itself was so
supportive of the pharmaceutical
companies was something just absolutely
staggering to see and to see the left
go after the poor so assiduously my
understanding is this you tell me what
you think about this it's like if you
really cared for poor people and you
wanted their lives to improve the best
thing you could possibly do as far as I
can tell is to lower is to drive energy
costs down to the lowest possible level
and to make energy provision your number
one priority at
um everywhere especially in the
developing world but also for the poor
in the west and the reason for that is
that there's there's no difference
between energy and work and there's no
difference between work and productivity
now you might say two things you might
respond well the planet has too many
people on it we can't encourage that
sort of thing and if you make people
Rich then the rich people destroy the
environment faster but both of those
things are nonsense because we've seen a
massive increase in population over the
last 40 years and all the bloody
doomsayers like Paul Eric who has more
sins on his conscience than anyone else
I can possibly think of has said that by
the year 2000 we were going to be out of
Commodities and everybody was going to
be starving to death and we're not out
of Commodities and they're a lot cheaper
and we have more food and people only
starve to death for political reasons
and as we've got more people we've
actually got richer so that's all bloody
complete backwards nonsense and then not
only that is that the data that I've
looked at and I've looked at it with
Bjorn lomberg or through his eyes is
that if you can get people in the
developing World up to about five
thousand dollars a year in gross
domestic product on average they start
taking a long-term view of the future
and start becoming concerned about local
environmental issues and we'll take that
burden onto themselves so that top-down
centralist globalist utopians don't have
to enforce all this idiocy on them so
like am I missing something here you
know have I gone down some bloody
right-wing Rabbit Hole or is this is
this just the Stark truth so I think the
key for me Jordan in all of this
discussion is electricity availability
and this is Yes Energy in general
matters but more specifically it's
electricity and let me get on one point
that I think is critical when we talk
about compassion we talk about humanism
because my favorite line these days is
energy realism is humanism and when
we're going to be realistic about energy
and we're going to be energy humanists
we have to look at the lens of of energy
and energy availability in particular
and how it affects women and girls
electricity frees women and girls from
the pump the stove and the wash tub uh
you remember uh uh the the new dealers
here in the U.S when they wanted to uh
bring electricity to rural areas many of
these politicians George Norris Sam
Rayburn uh George Norris from Nebraska
Sam Rayburn from Texas Lyndon Johnson
from Texas they had seen their their
mothers wash clothes by hand they wanted
them to be liberated from uh from that
from the wash tub they'd seen this kind
of back-breaking Labor and this is the
key
um there are something like uh who's the
the Swedish demographer uh who recently
died
um uh he estimated there were five
billion people in the world today
walking around in clothes that have been
washed by hand well they've been frozen
yes uh uh now she what is this like
what's his first name uh Hans roslings
forgive me Hans Crossing yes hands
wrestling brilliant he did that yes
brilliant he did that amazing uh video I
I think he gave a TED Talk where he was
talking about his grandmother and his
grandmother his folks had bought a
washing machine as grandmother came over
when they first time they used the
washing machine and she wanted to start
it right because it was a miracle to her
he said that in fact he said the washing
machine to my grandmother was a miracle
so when we think about electricity and
energy availability this is the key for
women and girls because if they don't
have it they are effectively slaves to
the household chores and so rossly
hounds rossling's point five billion
people in the world today are walking
around in clothes that have been washed
by hand that means they're two and a
half billion women and girls who are
washing those clothes by hand at every
minute every hour every day that they're
not why that they're washing clothes by
hand they're not in the library they're
not in school they're not able to get a
job outside the home so there is this
they're also not contributing their
brain power to the rest of us you know
can you imagine can you imagine the
economic value of 2 billion brains that
are occupied in menial labor that could
otherwise be freed up I mean there's
there's 2 000 women in that group that
are one in a million you know and that's
genius level man we could use those
people and the fact that that we're
locking up that that degree of neural
architecture in these menial tasks to
not save the planet while we're making
electricity more unreliable and more
expensive it's just it's it's absolute
CR it's beyond incompetence into the
realm of absolutely criminal as far as
I'm concerned it's uh it's just it's
just it's an it's an it's it's and it's
an excessive Focus I think on the look
here's my line climate change is a
concern it's not our only concern we
have to balance our action on climate
with our other other issues but the
overall point I think that it's
absolutely essential is that regardless
of what we think what you and I think
about CO2 emissions and how many parts
per million is the perfect number if
we're facing more extreme weather hotter
colder more extreme longer I mean it's
been crazy hot here in Texas well if
that's the case we're going to need a
lot more energy not less we're going to
need a lot more reliable energy not less
and yet the trends are for this effort
to rely more on weather dependent
Renewables so for that's the other part
Jordan that's if we're facing more
extreme weather why in the world would
we make our most important energy
Network dependent on the weather it's
like on the face of it it makes no sense
I mean I don't want to get too tanked
with it's just crazy town
using the internet without expressvpn is
like not paying attention to the safety
demonstration on a flight most of the
time you'll probably be fine but what if
one day that weird yellow mask drops
down from overhead and you have no idea
what to do it's better to be safe than
sorry every time you connect to an
unencrypted Network cafes hotels
airports any hacker on the same network
can gain access to your personal data
such as your passwords and financial
details it doesn't take much technical
knowledge to hack someone just some
cheap Hardware hackers can make up to
one thousand dollars per person selling
personal info on the dark web expressvpn
increase a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet
hackers cannot steal your sensitive data
I love expressvpn for how easy it is to
use I just fire up the app and click one
button to get protected secure your
online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com Jordan that's exp r e s s
vpn.com Jordan and get three extra
months free
expressvpn.com Jordan
[Music]
let's walk through this again too and so
I'd sure like you to push back on me as
much as you could so this is what I've
watched in the course of my lifetime so
in the 1970s
we were going to run out of fossil fuels
and that was a big bloody catastrophe
for everyone for about six years after
1972 in the energy crisis and that
turned out to be complete rubbish we're
not running out of fossil fuels and we
won't partly I mean I think it was Exxon
two weeks ago announced that they had a
new fracturing technology that could
double the known store of fossil fuels
in the U.S which is like should have
been front page headline news everywhere
because oh my God we have twice as many
fossil fuels as we thought and so isn't
that really something and the EU
Americans have become absolute bloody
magicians at extracting out fossil fuel
from these uh huge reserves that you
have like the Shale beds and it's not
going to run out and that's partly
because as the price goes up people's
incentives to
um to extract out even more of the
fossil fuel reserves we know are there
increases and the technology uh Geniuses
just get better and better at doing it
so we're not going to run out of fossil
fuel that's not going to happen that was
wrong okay next
the next thing that happened in the
1970s is uh global cooling where the
planet's going to freeze and that
happened for about five years and then
that turned out to be nonsense and then
the next thing that happened was global
warming and then that turned out to be
not true enough to be sustainable and
somehow The Narrative switched to oh
well it's climate change now and that is
one Weasley proposition man it's like oh
change so now you have a get out of jail
free card for all of your idiot policies
because of the climate is changing and
that means increased variability now
I've looked at the data on Hurricane
frequency for example there's no
evidence whatsoever that hurricanes are
increasing in frequency and to the
degree that they're more expensive it's
only because people are building more
and more expensive properties in
Hurricane prone zones then we also have
Bjorn Lombard's data showing that even
if we accept the ipcc's climate
predictions and I don't necessarily
think we should that we will be you know
some degree poorer
then how much richer we would have been
100 years from now right and so he
thinks we can handle that no problem
with a with an iota of intelligence and
some but then I'm wondering too you tell
me what you think about this I've been
watching The Greening data
now the world has greened 15 since the
year 2000 and that is a law it's an area
of leave twice the size of the
continental U.S that's a lot of extra
leaves and interestingly enough
it's greened in exactly the areas that
the climate catastrophists told us would
be in at most risk because they presumed
that the semi-arid areas the Arid areas
would expand out into the semi-arid
areas and the deserts would grow well
the desert isn't growing the Sahara is
actually shrinking especially on the
south end and the reason it's shrinking
is because more carbon dioxide has
allowed plants to thrive and when they
Thrive they can close their breathing
pores which means they don't need as
much water and now they're growing in
semi-arid areas all over the world plus
crop yields have gone up so like
I'm not familiar with all the data
you're you're throwing out there and I I
know these arguments and here's how I
keep my sanity Jordan is that I I don't
I don't get into the you know what is
how many parts per million is the right
number I you know we can argue about the
climate science
my Approach is very simple look if we're
going to agree that we need to do
something what's the best policy right
if as I said climate change is a concern
it's not our only concern so what is the
way forward what do we if we accept that
we are facing some risk how do we deal
with this risk what is the best no
regrets policy so I've been saying now
for more than a dozen years natural gas
to nuclear this is the way forward and
this is the part that just you know as I
said grills my cheese chaps my hide on
this Angola deal
um and it's on my sub stack Robert
brice.substack.com
um let them eat solar panels right the
export import Bank of the United States
is not funding a natural gas-fired power
our plant in Angola even though Angola
has trillions of cubic feet of available
natural gas instead we're funding a
solar panel project I mean this makes no
sense whatsoever so if we're serious
about reducing emissions and bringing
more people out of the dark and into the
light which I think is incumbent on the
wealthy countries to help developing
countries do that how do we do that
natural gas resources globally Jordan
are just they're not abundant they're
super abundant they're geographically
widespread and and there is an enormous
amount of stranded gas look at the huge
offshore fields that have been
discovered off of Africa uh Tanzania
other countries including Angola
enormous natural gas resources that have
barely been tapped well some of that gas
is going to be exported into the global
market into Europe and advanced
countries or developed countries but
Africa
those resources and to prevent them from
doing so I think is just as you say I
think it's morally wrong I think it's
it's Anatomy I mean it should be people
should be shouting from the rooftop
saying no we should be helping these
countries come out of the dark we should
be helping them develop because that's
incumbent upon us
way or at least not getting in their way
so then natural gas to nuclear I'll just
finish this other point this is one of
the things that again to me when I look
at these big climate ngos I don't call
them environmental groups I don't call
them green groups because I don't think
they are either they're ngos they're
climate activist groups and by the way
they're spending four and a half billion
dollars a year I've documented this
that's their budgets they're just
enormous but they're almost to a purse
almost all of them are anti-nuclear well
if we're serious about CO2 I mean it
makes no sense my line is if you're
anti-carbon dioxide and anti-nuclear you
are pro-blackout well I'm anti-blackout
pro-starvation well right so we need to
be helping develop this technology and
these are the things that I think are
positive now we can we can focus on a
lot of things that are negative and I
will grant you there are many negative
things that are happening and we can
throw rocks at the ngos and all the
climate idiocy that's happening in terms
of this uh or the the policy in idiocy
rather around this but what we're seeing
in the wake of the Russia Ukraine war
that I think is really encouraging
Jordan is a move toward nuclear Romania
a lot of the countries uh France just uh
Finland just opened Aqua just Sweden
just said we're gonna we're we're
bagging our renewable push we're going
to build nuclear plants just yesterday
was June 29th uh EDF group in France
said we're going to build two more
nuclear reactors the U.S tremendous
amount of momentum and money behind new
nuclear now there are a lot of friction
points including fuel availability
because the Russians have uh are
producing 46 percent I think over 40
percent of the global uranium enrichment
Market is in Saskatchewan has the
biggest uranium reserves in the world
and they're bloody untouched and in our
idiot country you know we have all these
uh fossil fuel reserves but we have we
have tremendous stores of of nuclear uh
fuel as well of uranium and Canada
actually has good nuclear technology
that can do reactor is a good reaction
and Canada is another good story and I'm
working on a new documentary it's going
to be out this fall it's called juice uh
Power politics and the grid and one of
the the people we're featuring is one of
your Canadian colleagues Chris Kiefer
he's done a remarkable job in in uh this
revitalization of the Canadian nuclear
sector that you're you're going to
rebuild some of your can-do reactors
you're building an SMR I think at
Darlington with a BX BRX 300 so I won't
say it's all due to to Dr Kiefer and
he's a remarkable Story by himself he's
an emergency room podcast guesty oh you
should put us in touch when you touch
absolutely oh yeah no he's he's got he's
got a lot of Elvis he's six feet nine
he's just this big presence but he
almost single-handedly Jordan has he has
um ignited this new rebirth in Canadian
nuclear and it's been a Marvel so that
Canadia is kind of Canada rather has
kind of jumped into the lead uh but it's
not so Canada Romania uh China's
building dozens of reactors uh the
Russians are still pushing out their
their technology uh uh uh Britain France
uh Poland I mentioned Romania so there
is amidst all the crazy town that's
happening the the one I think thing that
is positive that's occurred in the wake
of Russia's invasion of Ukraine is an is
a recognition that if we're serious
about reducing emissions or just more
serious about not covering the the
landscape littering the landscape uh
with stupid wind turbines and solar
panels we're going to embrace Nuclear So
I think that's a very positive uh thing
that is happening and one that I'm
watching well and where do you see where
are you particularly optimistic on the
nuclear technology front do you what do
you think of small modular reactors and
the molten salt Technologies and so
forth that people seem to be my my sense
is that the way forward is something
like
standardized production of small modular
nuclear reactors so that the cost per
unit can be brought down and so that the
systems can be distributed without
having to build an immense amount of
high of of like transmission wires so
but I don't like I'm I'm trying to get
up to speed on that but but I'm not
precisely so where are you particularly
optimistic on the nuclear front so well
like you I see a lot of promise with
nuclear in general so what about smrs
which is small modular reactors there
are a lot of technologies that are being
developed now and a bunch of different
companies that are pushing them out so
the GE Hitachi new scale here in the U.S
XXX energy uh Kairos oklo
um it remains to be seen which one will
will be the one that makes it to Market
well among the most interesting ones to
me Jordan uh is X energy that's a high
temperature gas reactor
um and they just recently did a deal
with Dao and Dao announced in fact Dao I
think took an equity position in X
energy and and they are planning to
deploy four of their smrs at one of
their Dao's chemical plant in Seadrift
Texas which is uh fairly close to Corpus
Christi if memory serves well to me
what's interesting about that one of
those high temperature gas right so
that's a safer design inherently than
than a water-based reactor
um second it's that Dow is looking at
this endow is an old line Chemical
Company we're very conservative they're
looking at this and saying we think this
is the right technology and further that
they're saying we're going to use the
high temperature process heat so we can
make chemicals instead of burning gas to
produce high temperature right to make
oh yeah oh oh so it has that additional
Advantage right you want to walk through
do you want to walk through that why
that's important for people well sure so
industrial process heat is needed for a
lot of different things right refining
mining uh chemical production so
industrial consumers use a lot of
electricity they use a lot of of energy
in general so if you have a source of
high temperature heat then you could
produce high temperature Steam and then
use that for your processing of whatever
it is that you're doing so for Dow to
make this deal with X energy I think is
indicative of where the market the
industrial consumers are seeing things
how they see the market moving right and
so that's quite intriguing
um I also think Rolls-Royce might be an
interesting play and you know Brit
Britain now is there technology the
right one we don't know yet I think
we're kind of in the I'd compare it
maybe to the early days of video is it
going to be VHS or is it going to be
betamax right is it you know and which
one will prevail but I think your
general idea that we should have one or
two designs is the right one right that
is why France was so successful in
deploying nuclear right they picked one
nuclear reactor design and then they
just stamped them out so that any
engineer from any nuclear plant in
France can go work at another plant
because all the instrumentation all
every all this equipment is the same
um I didn't know this until I went to
Paris a few years ago and I was talking
to a nuclear engineer in France and he
said at Three Mile Island which of
course is a nuclear plant where he had
an accident here in the U.S there were
two reactors but the two reactors had
two different control rooms because they
were built by two different companies
well that makes no sense at all right so
if we're going to see a new a new
Renaissance of nuclear there are a lot
of friction points and I'll talk about
those in a minute but we're going to
have to speed up the regulatory regime
and that means the nuclear Regulatory
Commission here in the U.S we've had
some U.S companies domicile in Canada
because they think it's it will be
easier path to licensure if they start
in Canada and then come back to the U.S
the Europeans are going to have a
different type of of Licensing uh
procedures than the us but the NRC is a
big roadblock the other is the fuel part
so this is where I think the friction
parts are uh and I want to be very sober
about this Jordan because I was in Japan
earlier this year is very fortunate I'm
very lucky in my career to be able to
travel and see things and I went to
Fukushima daiichi and it was an
indelible experience for me I've been
pro-nuclear for more than a decade but
seeing the ruined reactors at Fukushima
daiichi and hearing the people from
Tokyo Electric Power Company talk about
how they're taking the reactors apart
slowly and the process that they're
going through and what they're doing and
then seeing what is actually happening
in Japan as well tepco is building a
coal-fired power plant on Tokyo bay
right the Japanese are embracing energy
realism the home of the Kyoto Protocol
they're not aiming at Net Zero that we
met with top government officials we met
with top industry officials I said so
what about your carbon emissions they
said yeah we're not we're not really
going to pursue those we're pursuing
energy Security First and I had one guy
just say very clearly look we live in a
bad neighborhood we got the Russians
over there the Chinese over there the
North Koreans over there we are going to
take care of our energy Security First
so I think Japan and more than any other
country in my recent experiences is a is
an indicator of how energy realism and
energy security is trumping concerns
about climate change and I think rightly
so the Japanese are nothing if not
practical so they're building 1.3
gigawatt coal-fired power plant on Tokyo
bay they're also building another 500
megawatts Ultra supercritical uh
coal-fired Power Plant uh forgot where
that one is and another five gigawatts
of gas-fired capacity so they're slowly
reopening their nuclear reactors but
they're also being very terrified
they're also very clear-eyed about where
they are going in the world and they're
saying energy security is our first
concern and we're going to take care of
that because our industry demands it and
so
um so these are positive the Chinese are
doing the same thing I mean the
challenge are are planning I think a
hundred nuclear plants something like
that over the upcoming decades but
they're also expanding their coal-fired
plants like mad which also makes an
absolute bloody mockery of anything
we're doing doing in the West on the
so-called climate front because
especially in a country like Canada
where our our emissions are so trivial
on the world stage that they're not
they're not even within the error margin
of of estimate for for carbon dioxide
effects and and that's and that's a
critical point that I think that you
know I've heard other people say this is
not original to me but the emissions
from the West in many ways don't matter
anymore because the story is in places
like Vietnam Bangladesh Pakistan India
China these are the places where
emissions are growing so rapidly and in
fact I spend a lot of time I nerd out on
spreadsheets and I I the statistical
review of world energy just came out so
I've been studying it very closely the
country that had the biggest and
absolute terms the biggest increase in
CO2 emissions last year was Indonesia
followed closely by India so these are
countries that have enormous populations
and are are still desperately energy
poor
um but let me return Nigeria kicks in
you know Nigeria is going to have more
people in it than China by the end of
the century eh so and and your point
there that we're seeing the huge growth
in in energy consumption among the
countries with the largest populations
it's like well that's pretty bloody
self-evident isn't it once those
countries start to pass a certain
threshold of Industrial Development that
is where all the action is going to be
on the climate energy front and so we
should be planning for that and you know
and
Vietnam is a good example of this and
I've written about Vietnam as well uh
recently on on my sub stack that here's
a country that is rapidly
industrializing major industrial
companies are moving to Vietnam to hedge
their bets about being in China so big
companies uh Nike Adidas Samsung Apple
to name a few locating in Vietnam and
suddenly Vietnam is power short so what
did Vietnam just announced their uh Viet
command as their their state-owned
Mining Company announced they're going
to expand their coal mining capacity by
15 this is the iron this is the iron law
of electricity what I call the iron law
of electricity uh nod to my friend Roger
Pilkey Jr who coined the iron law of
climate he said when faced between his
his Focus was face between climate
policy and economic growth economic
growth will win every time so I borrowed
Roger's idea and coined the iron law of
electricity which is people countries
and businesses will do whatever they
have to do to get the electricity they
need climate change is not their first
concern and this was evident in Japan
this was the part that really was a
sobering experience in going to Japan
but I've seen it myself I've seen people
in India stealing electricity in Beirut
where I talk about that I write about it
in my book
seeing the generator Mafia where pretty
much everyone in Lebanon pays two
electric bills one to edl the grid
operator and the other to the generator
Mafia who are the local entrepreneurs
they call them the mob they call them
the mafia but they're providing power
when the grid fails in Lebanon the grid
fails in Lebanon every day so this this
iron law of electricity I think is
another example in my view we have to be
realists energy realism is energy
humanism people are going to do whatever
they have to do because they're not
going to sit in the dark they're not
going to let their you know the the like
the the food in the fridge spoil they're
going to find a small generator they're
going to see yeah they're awesome
they're also not going to let Grandma
freeze to death in the winter I mean I
looked at domberg's data on the
consequences of lowering thermostat
temperatures just a few degrees and yeah
he estimated for example that a three if
I remember correctly and this is about
right that a Three Degree decrease in
thermostat temperature in the winter
kills 110 000 people in Europe that's
old people you know because old people
can't regulate their temperature very
well and so there's two things we need
to point out to everyone who's watching
and listening and the first is is that
if you raise energy costs imagine that
there's a pyramid of it of Economic
Development and there's
hundreds of millions or billions of
people who are sitting right on the
threshold of poverty they've climbed out
of absolute poverty so now they have
enough money so that they don't have to
worry about where lunch is coming from
but that's just where they're at and
they're barely there and if you increase
their energy cost to any degree at all
all you do is whack them down back down
into absolute abject poverty and then
they do things like slash and burn
agriculture and they burn dung and and
other you know very uh low energy dense
High polluting fuels yeah we're right
and they and then they pollute the
indoor atmosphere and that's really
really hard on their kids and their
elderly people as well and so you cannot
we got to say this over and over you
cannot raise Energy prices without
devastating the poor period the end and
and the more poor people you make as far
as I can tell the worst things are
actually for the planet rather than the
better and that this brings us to
another conundrum you know you pointed
out
um that the green types tend not only to
be anti-natural gas which is of course
completely insane but also anti-nuclear
and this points to the fundamental
underlying motivation as far as I'm
concerned is that it this green movement
isn't so much green certainly not as a
consequence of the fruits that is born
as it is both anti-industrial and
anti-human and those actually turn out
to be the same thing and you can tell in
these when push comes to shove cases
because the bloody greens if they were
actually concerned about carbon dioxide
output which is what they say we should
only be concerned about would be jumping
on board the nuclear wagon bandwagon in
a second saying well obviously we should
transition to nuclear because it's zero
carbon dioxide output and that's not
happening so that means as far as I'm
concerned that everything that their
fundamental narrative is a delusional
lie and it's got a malevolent twist in
it too and you can see that manifesting
itself in the refusal of these Western
uh ngos and and the World Bank and so
forth to lend money to developing
countries to try to raise them out of
poverty which is inexcusable
there's a certain well you know this
field better than I but there's a
certain puritanical part of this right
and a certain also I think a religious
fundamentalism and and I'm sure other
people have talked about this before I
know uh but there is there are many
overlaps between the Christian belief
and
um and these ideas around climate
catastrophism right that uh the that
we've sinned against the Earth right we
haven't sinned against God we sinned
against the Earth we need to repent we
need to use less do less and go back to
the Garden right and even Martin Luther
to you know you know keep going on this
just a hair longer he would recognize
carbon credits right you know like you
get a carbon Indulgence by buying some
offset because you flew to Fiji but let
me just build on your point about the
availability of hydrocarbons and how
important it is and uh Kirk Smith was a
professor at Cal Berkeley who died
recently and I cited him I think in my
latest book or in in my in my fourth
book power hungry but he documented and
was one one among the first researchers
to document the effects of indoor air
pollution on women and girls and you
know I was interviewing a climate
activist yesterday and by the way I
don't call it green energy I don't call
them green I call them climate activists
I don't call it green energy I don't
call it clean energy I called it alt
energy right because I don't think it's
green I don't think it's clean covering
the landscape with solar panels uh
destroying Landscapes with wind with
wind turbines I'm a long time critic of
the wind business proudly so they don't
like me I don't like them back okay
because I have you know I've documented
now for more than uh 10 years and on the
renewable rejection database which is on
my website uh robertbrice.com I've
documented nearly 400 rejections of wind
energy in the U.S from Maine to Hawaii
it's happening in Canada too by the way
in Ontario over 90 communities have
declared themselves unwilling hosts to
wind energy now you don't read about
this in the New York Times because it
doesn't fit the narrative but I digress
so back to the point about hydrocarbons
and Kirk Smith
indoor air pollution is one of the
leading killers of women and girls in
developing countries Kirk Smith and the
who I think the World Health
Organization documented something like
three or four million women a year women
and girls a year dying premature deaths
because of indoor air pollution because
they're cooking with dung or wheat straw
in in their homes
and and and Kirk Smith made this point
they need LPG they need butane they need
propane they need clean forget
electricity for just a minute let's
replace those low those low uh density
fuels at low low density High polluting
fuels with hydrocarbons that's a step
change in their standards of living and
so you know I but I'm with you in terms
of kind of your broader points here we
need more energy not less we choke and
and I'll I'll stop here because I could
go on and found the table here but
expensive energy is the enemy of the
poor and I remember very vividly I I
live in Austin which is of course you
know I I used to have friends here it's
a liberal Hub right but a friend of mine
a former acquaintance of mine he was
pounding the table oh Energy's too cheap
and I thought okay here you are you
vacation and you fly around the world
you go somewhere here there and they're
everywhere you're rich
and you're telling me energy is too
cheap I don't see it that way and I wait
I haven't talked to him in a long time
because of that because I just thought
you don't understand what you're talking
about expensive energy is the enemy of
the poor and yet so many of these
policies both in the developed countries
and the developing countries are aimed
and by these bilateral multilateral
lenders by policy makers at the state
level and federal level are aiming that
are creating policies that make energy
more expensive and I just think that's
just fundamentally wrong energy means
life and the absence of energy is death
to quote my friend doomberg
the Bible is the root of all wisdom
inspiration and spiritual nourishment
the Hallow app empowers you to explore
the Bible's profound teachings and to
effortlessly incorporate them into your
daily life
a great place to start while you deepen
your understanding of the Bible is to
check out father Mike schmitz's Bible in
a year available on the Hallow app for
brief daily readings and Reflections
here you can dive into an extensive
library of Bible reading plans
accompanied by insightful Reflections
and audio guided meditations whether
you're a seasoned Bible reader or just
starting your journey hallow provides a
platform for you to engage with
scripture like never before
studying the Bible's literary Brilliance
has influenced countless writers poets
and artists throughout history by
studying the Bible yourself you'll gain
a deeper appreciation for the power of
Storytelling symbolism and metaphor
enriching your understanding of
literature across different genres the
Hallow app also helps you connect with a
community of like-minded individuals
sharing experiences insights and
encouragement along the path to
spiritual growth download the app for
free at hollow.com Jordan you can set
reminders and track your progress along
the way enrich your education and
nurture your mind and soul today
download the Hallow app at hallow.com
Jordan that's hallow.com Jordan
hello.com Jordan for an exclusive
three-month free trial of all six
thousand plus prayers and meditations
I started to take this uh whole domain
of trouble particularly seriously when
watching what was happening in Europe
and starting to understand that
the West in its delusions of repentance
would sacrifice hundreds of millions of
people
um and literally sacrifice them on the
altar of Gaia to not save the planet
well virtue is signaling about how Indus
in the industrial Enterprise was
um unethical despite benefiting from
every single one of the gains that the
industrial revolution has produced and
being 100 absolutely unwilling to give
up any of it at all whatsoever under any
circumstances for ourselves like there's
no excuse for any of that now my
understanding is this is that we there's
a pretty clear developmental pathway
to cleaner and more reliable energy in
the long run it's something like well
you start at the very lowest rung with
with dung and with wheat straw and with
those things that and with wood scrap
wood so forth that can be burned that's
there in the local environment and it's
low energy dense it's expensive it runs
out easily it's unreliable it's
polluting you move from that to Coal now
you move to Coal because coal is
unbelievably plentiful and it's dirt
cheap and you can get a coal-fired plant
up and running with relatively uh
rudimentary technology and almost no
time flat and it's disadvantage in
particular is particulate pollution
although it also produces a lot of
carbon which I don't really care about
but the particulate pollution is a
problem you move from that to oil or
natural gas and you move from that to
nuclear like do we know this or or not
is this just like it can can we rest
assured that this is a reasonable
developmental pathway and one that we
should be pursuing well this is the way
it's been happening for a long time now
I mean that is the way the world has
deep carbonized over time my friend
Jesse osabelle at Rockefeller you know
Rockefeller university has documented
this and uh and and shown we are
gradually decarbonizing but that
decarbonizing is happening as is
underway in developed countries and
we're they're you know dozens of
underdeveloped countries that are just
getting started right they're still at
the biomass stage and there's this this
claim oh well we can LeapFrog they can
the alt energy crowd the climate crowd
says oh well they don't need
hydrocarbons they'll jump right to
Renewables no wrong I mean while that's
true in some cases in rural areas where
solar and batteries are going to be the
solution Africa is rapidly urbanizing
here's a quick quick comparison so
you're you're a Canadian is in rough
terms there are 35 million Canadians
they use uh compared to 1.4 billion
Africans roughly the same amount of
electricity that's the disparity that
we're talking about now there's no
numbers aren't exact but in rough terms
that's a comparison so the need for
electricity is overwhelming globally
Jordan it's just enormous so how do we
you know this is the part where look we
can talk climate change all day long
what's the right number what's the wrong
number what the you know who's doing the
right thing who's the wrong thing what's
the best no regret strategy as we look
to the Future and I think again of end
to end natural gas to nuclear these are
the ways that we are that no regrets
okay so climate maybe we find in a few
years well we were wrong about climate
change I don't necessarily I'm not
making that argument but when it comes
the why natural gas or nuclear both are
lower no carbon the Technologies are
very well developed they're available in
numerous countries and they can scale at
relatively low cost so all of those
things together to me and make this a
no-brainer
um and I'm going to pound the table
continue pounding the table on that
because this is the challenge of our
time I mean when we look around the
world this is when we look around the
world and we think as humanists right if
we're going to be humanists what do we
do to help developing countries come out
of the dark to develop how do we help
countries like Vietnam they're going to
look out for Vietnam first that is that
you know every country is going to do
what is the right pathway for them so
how does how could the U.S how could the
how could Canada how could the European
countries help those countries well help
them build develop their natural gas and
help them deploy nuclear energy at scale
new Next Generation passively safe uh
modular reactors these are the things
that are going to help us decarbonize
and Electrify these countries that are
so desperately poor right now
okay so let's turn to two things here
all right sure I would like first of all
I I'd like to pick your brain
momentarily about coal yeah there's lots
of coal and so if we could figure out
how to use that coal that would be real
good because there's lots of it and it's
everywhere and so how are we doing on
the Clean Coal front
how good are the are the modern
coal-fired plants well in terms of for
example getting rid of particulate
pollution sure well I'll make a joke
first which I think Clean Coal is kind
of oxymoronic oxymoronic like Military
Intelligence or family vacation right or
jumbo shrimp right
um You can make cleaner coal and so I
mentioned Japan earlier they're building
new coal-fired power plants what are
they doing they're using Ultra
supercritical technology which is the
the highest level of combustion you get
you ring more Watt hours for every
kilogram of coal that you burn so that
is the optimum that's if we're going to
burn coal let's let's use ultra super
critical technology but that's more
expensive and not all countries are
willing to do that instead they're
building subcritical plants which is are
the most common ones
um well you think that would be a place
for potential subsidy then to help the
countries that are building coal plants
build better ones absolutely cared but I
think but I think it's important to put
it in historical context so I'm I've
written about the history this is one of
the points I make in a question of power
is when you look at Edison in 1882 will
he use coal on his on the Pearl Street
Station in lower Manhattan he burned
coal right well we're still now 140
years 141 years later Cole globally
still has 35 percent of the global
electric sector market right so and and
you mentioned China before uh Global
energy monitor which is a clearly an
anti-coal group in in February put out a
report last year China permitted two new
coal plants a week right right so India
is building new coal plants Bangladesh
Vietnam uh uh numerous other countries
Indonesia Indonesia had as I mentioned
before has the highest or biggest
increase in CO2 emissions last year of
any country in the world why because
they rapidly expanded their coal Fleet
so coal is here to stay it for decades
to come that is a fact these plants that
are being built now are going to
continue running so you know America
because you know cheering on the closure
of our coal plants well I think that's
probably problematic in terms of
reliability but that's a different
discussion but so
so geographically widespread widespread
It's relatively cheap and it's super
abundant so that is why so many
countries if we close all the bloody
coal plants in the west it also means
that we won't be able to put our
technological prowess to work to make
the coal plants cleaner and it also
means it'll knock us out of the
international market for the development
of coal-fired plants which as you
pointed out is going to be a growth
industry for you know into the
foreseeable future so that seems like a
stupid idea to me all things considered
yeah I I don't know necessarily about
that because there are a lot of
companies that have that kind of
technology that can deploy the Japanese
the Malaysians the Chinese but but I
think the key here is just to think
about it you know it's a global story
right and if we're going to it's not
it's not Texas warming it's not is
Canada warming or America warm it's
global warming it's global climate
change we're going to deal with this we
have to have some sensibility about the
the the the world as a collection of
Nations that want to try and address
this well what is going to be the weight
of it's what is the way forward then
it's going to be to make cleaner
electricity cheaper and I think that
means natural natural gas or nuclear
well we could run around panicking about
the sky falling even though it isn't and
we could lie constantly about Net Zero
and make everyone poor and we could hurt
the hell out of the third world while
not doing anything on the climate front
instead which seems to be what we're
doing you know these these Net Zero
Advocates first of all that entire that
entire what terminology just grates on
me it's like there is like Net Zero is a
cliche not a policy and zero anything is
impossible because we're not going to
get to zero carbon output obviously ever
and we shouldn't even aim at that
because it's stupid you know even if we
could reduce it 80 that would be fine
but I I think that narrative is running
out though I think I you know if you
look at what's happening in Europe I
think the politicians particularly in
Germany we talked about Germany earlier
okay too the UK as well they're looking
forward and saying you know we're not
going to make net zero right we're this
is we're gonna have to throttle this
back the German green party has been has
lost some remarkable recent elections
got shellacked the German uh the German
voters are looking around at this and
they're saying wait a minute this is
terrible for us so I I think some of
this another positive sign in addition
to the expansion of nuclear I think
we're seeing more energy realism and
thank thank the Lord for that I mean
it's taken a while yep all right so
let's talk about let's take another
attack on the environmental front now
you've rather extensively about the
dangers the environmental dangers of
wind power and you're also well you you
made a crack earlier about let them eat
solar panels and so you obviously have
some misgivings on the solar front so
let's start with on the Wind front so my
understanding I'm going to lay out a few
things and tell me if I'm right or wrong
so first of all Siemens last week two
weeks ago announced that they were
having catastrophic and I think the CEO
said something like I can't believe how
catastrophic our problems are with our
wind turbines that's not a good thing
for a CEO to say the wind turbines
they're unreliable they obviously don't
work when the wind isn't blowing which
is quite a lot of the time and that's
really a problem at night when the solar
panels also don't work they're they
don't have uh proven track record they
only seem to last about 17 years God
nobody knows what to do with them when
they're decommissioned and they're very
expensive to decommission they're
killing whales like mad hypothetically
they seem to be really hard on birds and
so this just isn't working out very well
and so now am I missing something on the
Wind front and then we could turn
no I think you hit pretty well all of
the issues here uh let's set whales
aside let's set the wildlife issues
aside I'm an avid bird watcher and this
again is one area that just absolutely
just I I it it's unbelievable to me you
know that that the wind industry gets a
pass when it comes to killing some of
our most iconic Wildlife including bald
and golden eagles but set that aside for
a minute let's talk about just basic
physics so one of the key ways or the
the essential keys to understanding our
energy and Power Systems is to look at
the physics metric of power density so
we want high power density that's one
reason why I'm so pro-nuclear super high
power density we're talking 2 000 watts
per square meter roughly so uh energy is
the ability to do work power is the rate
at which work gets done I'm sorry energy
is the ability to work that's right
power is the rate at which work gets
done we measure power in Watts so we
want High watts per square meter nuclear
explain that a bit more explain walk
everybody through what energy density
means because it's I'm sure it's a
sophisticated concept and yeah and it is
people need to understand it and and
it's and to be clear it's power density
so what is power it's a measure of
energy flow it's measured in watts so
you have different kinds of Power
density and and power is a measure of
energy flow okay so you can have barrels
of oil in the ground are energy barrels
per day are power we energy is worthless
unless we can make it flow and the more
we can make it flow the better so we
want more power flow which is Watts so
power density is a measure of energy
flow from a given area of volume or mass
and you're right it's not well
understood fairly simple in physics
terms but it's essential to understand
it because power density determines the
shape of our energy and Power Systems
everywhere always all the time period
okay so we want high power density
sources ethanol is extraordinarily low
because it relies on on on
photosynthesis about one tenth of a watt
per square meter wind energy I don't
care where you put it is one watt per
square meter period end of story Elvis
has left the building one watt per
square meter solar is better about 10
watts per square meter so if I'm going
to pick my Renewables I think solar has
more attributes better attributes than
wind okay so what do we see though
because of this low power density with
wind it requires enormous amounts of
land so and when it requires enormous
amounts of land well you're impacting
more people and the more you the only
way to expand the output of wind is to
capture more land it's axiomatic so to
give you an
analysis vatslav smill those are your
fellow Canadian has written about this
he estimated back in 2010 to for the U.S
to meet its electric demands with wind
would require a land area twice the size
of the State of California about eight
years ago uh I'm sorry eight years later
uh David Keith and Lee Miller at Harvard
did a similar analysis came up with the
same number if you were going to
generate all the electricity in the US
with wind energy you need a land area of
900 000 square kilometers twice the size
of the State of California okay that's
clear Jesse Jenkins from Princeton
recently wrote a piece in in in Mother
Jones again saying that the footprint of
wind energy is massive well this is a
problem Jordan I spend a lot of time in
Rural America and I these people I was
in I I travel I meet these people they
some of them become my friends they're
rural landowners rural Farmers rural
ranchers we don't want 600 foot high
wind turbines in our neighborhood we
don't want to look at red blinking
lights all night every night for the
rest of our lives they these wind
projects despite all these claims from
the win business they hurt property
values and they produce enormous amounts
of noise pollution which are is bad for
human health it disrupts sleep this has
been proven again so these are polluting
machines they're visually polluting
their blights on the landscape they hurt
human health they hurt property values
and none of this matters to the Sierra
clubbers or these alt energy crowd
because climate change right they
they're like these totems these climate
change scarecrows that's what I call
them right that they're somehow going to
solve climate change no they're not
they're only being deployed because of
the tax credits which are enormously
lucrative for the companies that are
doing this so just another quick point
this tax credit pursuit of the tax
credits what I call subsidy mining is
what's driving this deployment of solar
and wind but particularly the wind
business so look at what happened in
Madison County Iowa I wrote about this
was in Forbes some time ago but
um Mid-American Energy is subsidiary of
Berkshire Hathaway owned by or
controlled by uh Warren Buffett who in
2014 said the only reason to build wind
turbines is to get the tax credits okay
back to Madison County
Berkshire Hathaway A Mid-American wanted
to build a wind project in Madison
County Madison County passes an
ordinance saying we don't you know no
more wind projects they effectively the
ordinance said banned new wind projects
they got sued by Mid-American Energy
imagine if Chevron or Exxon did that it
would be front page news in the New York
Times and instead crickets no reporting
on this at all if the oil and gas
industry was acting as aggressively as
the wind industry has against rural
Americans and in fact in nextera energy
sued one of your fellow Canadians Esther
Reitman filed a slap suit against her in
Canadian court because she was opposing
one of their win projects and called
nextera Next error on her website they
sued her and said they fired they put a
slap suit on her the slams were designed
to stop people from being intimidated by
large organizations that was the bloody
plan there right so imagine if this if
the next if oil the oil industry did
that but here is an American company
suing a Canadian a Canadian Court I mean
the way these companies have acted in
terms of corporate responsibility it's
just crazy I mean it's just this be in
this pursuit of subsidies what they've
done from a corporate responsibility
standpoint it's just like at the oil and
gas industry acted this way it would be
they would be pilloried and yet because
it's alt energy they get a free pass
in a world filled with uncertainties
it's crucial to be ready for whatever
comes your way whether it's a natural
disaster a sudden emergency or
unforeseen circumstances having a
reliable food storage system can provide
you with peace of mind and the assurance
that you and your loved ones will be
well taken care of right now my Patriot
Supply is offering major savings on
their four-week emergency food kit to
help you stay prepared for anything go
to preparewithpeterson.com and grab this
special price before it ends your
four-week emergency food kit provides
over 2 000 calories each day for optimal
strength and energy in stressful
situations you can enjoy a wide variety
of my Patriot Supply and can even
customize your supply they offer an
ultimate breakfast kit a mega protein
kit with real meat and even a
gluten-free kit the best part is each
meal is delicious and has a shelf life
of 25 years don't wait for a disaster to
strike before taking action invest in
your safety and well-being by securing
your food storage today go to prepare
with Peter dot com and get major savings
on your four-week emergency supply kit
go to preparewithpeterson.com right now
let's prepare with peterson.com
and so what's happening on the bird
front as far as you're concerned with
regards to windmills
you know I'm an avid bird watcher and
have been for more than 30 years
in 1990 I can pull the story up in fact
I wrote a piece for the Christian
Science monitor back then about bird
kills and open oil pits in West Texas
and and New Mexico
um and for violations of the migratory
bird treaty act and at that time the
fish and wildlife service estimated that
the oil and gas industry through their
own negligence was killing about 600 000
migratory bird migratory Birds a year
they the fish and wildlife service and
the Department of Justice brought
something like 200 cases against the oil
and gas industry prosecuted them rightly
so and the oil and gas industry to their
credit cleaned it up they put Nets over
their pits they closed their pits today
the wind industry is killing at least
that many birds probably more we don't
know and there is no accountability
because they're not required to report
these deaths they have been prosecuted
in very rare occasions but it's this oh
and the justification as well oh well
these these birds are going to get hurt
by climate change sometime in the future
oh yeah yeah
you're you're killing them now
because you think it might help in the
future well that's just crazy policy
that makes no sense whatsoever yeah and
you don't do that with people either you
don't get I mean this is and yet there's
a free this is a free pass I mean we
haven't talked about the whales we can
talk about that as well but but this
idea that oh we're going to kill them
because we might have some climate
change in the future and I'll return to
it I'll return that I'll return to next
era just one quick point last year
thankfully they got prosecuted by the
Department of Justice why because in
Wyoming next era had been warned by the
fish and wildlife service three times
not to build a wind project in known
Golden Eagle habitat they did it anyway
and so they were prosecuted and I was
glad to see it under the migrant under
the uh I think it was just under the
migratory bird treaty act they should
have been criminally prosecuted Under
The Endangered Species Act uh bald and
golden eagle protection act and the
migratory bird treaty act that said they
paid a fine but the fine they paid was
less than the amount that they're going
to earn from the tax credits for
building the wind farm in the first
place so there are perverse incentives
at hand here and um I I I I I I words
fail me because I I do I care about
Wildlife but I think this is the death
of environmentalism climatism has
replaced care for the environment and
this idea oh we'll just pave this rural
Countryside with wind turbines and solar
panels in the name of climate change but
are you out of your mind man we need to
we need small well we need small
Footprints it's also the case too that
this unidimensional Mania in
relationship to carbon dioxide is
stopping us from solving environmental
problems that could at least in
principle be addressed like I looked
into the environmental literature in
detail about 15 years ago and my
conclusion for better or worse was that
one of the stupidest things we were
doing was continually overfishing the
coastal shells in the ocean
and we do that like it's to call it
devastating is to barely even scratch
the surface I think we've eradicated
something like 95 percent of the ocean
life on the coastal shelves and that's
about where the life is because you need
sunlight for life and you need the
shelves so it's a bloody catastrophe and
it's impossible even to get people's
attention focused on that because
everybody who hypothetically has an
environmental concern is leaping up and
down about carbon dioxide and that means
that every other problem and there are
plenty of them and they are serious
problems and some of them are remediable
they're just ignored completely so you
get a you get a get out of jail pass for
any form of Industrial Development that
claims carbon dioxide remediation as its
goal and you get a moral pass if you
jump up and down about carbon dioxide
hard enough because you're saving the
planet even if you're not doing any of
the difficult work that would be
necessary to actually do something
useful on the environmental front plus
you're sacrificing the poor not to help
not to do anything but but make them
poorer and more likely to pollute so
this looks like a three-way catastrophe
to me well and this is obvious in in the
development of offshore wind on the U.S
east Coast where these and these ngos
these climate ngos that in the past
Audubon Society Sierra Club Etc would
have been jumping up and down to protect
the North Atlantic right whale from the
encroachment of offshore wind develop
offshore development I mean imagine if
it was the offshore of the oil and gas
industry was trying to develop and put
hundreds because that's the goal
hundreds of Offshore platforms in the
middle of known North Atlantic right
whale habitat a critically endangered
species less than 350 or so specimens
left on the on the planet imagine if
this was the oil and gas industry doing
that they would these groups would be
raising hell I mean I mean they would be
laying down they would be blocking the
trucks and instead because it's the wind
industry and largely being developed by
Foreign companies not even American
companies it's it's what Michael
schellenberger calls the environmental
betrayal and I think that's the exact
right word I'm old enough to remember
you know save the whales and that you
know was kind of parodied like you know
save the gay baby whales for Jesus right
you know this was kind of like this was
the kind of almost a joke right but that
environmentalism right did and I call it
that I'm working on an essay on the
death of environmentalism because I
think that's what we're seeing that's
what we're seeing that this this idea of
protecting Landscapes or protecting
Wildlife has been has been forsaken for
climatism what we've and what I call
climatism and renewable energy fetishism
so instead instead of a focus on
preserving Landscapes preserving
wildlife and and and and that that real
deep green ethic has been replaced by
this idea that any wind turbine is a
good wind turbine any solar panel is a
good solar panel and it is most obvious
I think in this uh well not just in the
onshore wind issue which I've documented
and the rejections of solar by the way
on the the solar rejections on the
renewable rejection database I think
we're at 130 or more rejections or
restrictions but this climatism this new
renewable fetishism I think is most
obvious when it comes to the the North
Atlantic right whales and the
development of offshore wind on the east
coast of the United States
sad to see so so the way it looks to me
like this is that people
people's reputations are extremely
important to them because they signal
their position in the hierarchy and the
higher you are in the hierarchy the more
stable your nervous system is and the
more positive emotion you expect you
experience and so and plus all sorts of
other benefits accrue to you because
people if you have a good reputation
people flock to you so reputation really
matters so that means that there's an
Avenue open constantly for false Avenues
to reputation enhancement and that's
what Psychopaths and narcissists do but
it's also what ideologues offer because
they tell people look
um if you're a good person you stand up
against problems here's the problem
which in this case would be carbon
dioxide thus you could be a good person
all things considered and have your
reputation enhanced merely by standing
up against carbon dioxide takes
absolutely no work on your part
whatsoever you just have to protest and
complain you don't actually have to
solve problems and now you're a good
person and now that's a pre-packaged
solution especially for young people who
are looking for moral virtue say well
all you have to do is be anti-industrial
and anti-carbon dioxide and now you're
now your reputation is significantly
enhanced and anyone who stands in your
way is like a devil and and evil and so
that's the that's the religious Nexus
that we're dealing with here and the
problem with that is as you're pointing
out is that well first of all it's
really hard on the poor and second it
sacrifices all the real problems to the
this pseudo problem solution or pseudo
problem pseudo-solutions
and and so now and so now this is
destructive and so now the solution is
to go throw some soup on some paintings
in the museum yeah right and right we're
just like oh I'm going to protest by by
being a vandal I mean and so that's
right yeah exactly well that that and
that signals that opposition to the you
know Colonial industrial Enterprise or
whatever the hell it is but there's a
certain but there's a certain pathetic
aspect to that I mean it's there these
these kids I call them a guy I'm going
to be 63 here pretty soon and I look at
them and I think
what are you doing I mean what is your
hope for the future have you no idea how
privileged you are living where you live
have you no sense of yourself in the
world relative to the rest of the planet
because uh we mentioned I think before
we started recording but I'm I'm happy
I'm working on a piece for the alliance
for responsible citizenship which you're
helping found in and I've written a long
paper and and on on electricity
availability in the developing world and
I've documented I went through using
data the latest data from our world and
in data they're 3.7 billion people in
the world today almost half of the world
population right now
uh that live in places where electricity
consumption is 12 1200 kilowatt hours or
less per capita per year that's about
the same 1200 per hour kilowatt hours
about the same amount of electricity is
consumed by a large kitchen refrigerator
in the United States so imagine this for
47 of the population on the planet today
is living in electricity poverty and
we're and we're complaining because our
electricity isn't you know from alt
energy or something I mean there is
there there there's a certain I think
Michael schellenberger calls it this
kind of nihilistic narcissism or so I'm
not sure exactly how he describes it but
but there's something about this only
presentism right that we only have right
now and none of him there's no history
there's no future and but there's no
sense of how we in the west are I mean I
I sometimes pinch myself I mean just how
lucky I am and not just in my career in
my family you know married to a
wonderful woman got great kids but in
terms of energy and energy availability
and then yet all we you know what we're
hearing and is what is dominating this
Administration and I say this is not a
partisan I'm not a Democrat I'm not a
republican I am disgusted but this Biden
Administration is the most
anti-hydrocarbon Administration in
American history and all and there it
seems like this climate issue is the
only anything they want to talk about
when you know an existential threat and
I'm thinking existential threat a
hundred thousand Americans died last
year of opioid overdoses I my son Jacob
is 23. within the last two months two
people that he knew two two kids two
boys that he knows I say young men
died of opioid overdoses here in Austin
that's a that's a Public Health crisis
and yet where has the Biden
Administration been on fentanyl where
are they on opioids why isn't he
pounding the damn Podium saying we have
to do something about this instead he's
standing up and bragging about some
stupid 900 million dollar loan to the
angle and so they can build solar panels
where are your priorities where is your
humanism I mean I I get worked on this
is part of the reason well this is part
okay so on the arc front the alliance
for responsible citizenship I mean we're
trying to do a couple of things first of
all we are working diligently with Bjorn
lomberg who's on board with the project
because I think of all the people that
I've met his ability to prioritize is
unparalleled and he's done very careful
empirical work showing what our priority
should be now it turns out to be
complicated and it's not you get to be a
good person if you shake your protest
sign up and down it's a lot more
complicated than that but we're also
concerned you know you said there's
something pathetic about watching these
young people for example glue themselves
to to paintings and I think that's where
pathetic degenerates into outright
Criminal by the way but I take your K
take your point with regards to pathetic
I mean part of the problem with uh
classic liberals and the conservative
types is that we we they haven't been
able to put to get forward a narrative
that's compelling on the genuine moral
Advanced front right and that's what
we're trying to do with the ark is we'd
like to say well you know why don't we
envision a future that we could all get
on board with voluntarily without fear
in compulsion and tyranny and that would
be something like well what would it
look like well how about we get how
about we take those 47 percent of people
that you just described who are barely
bloody well scraping by and get energy
to them so that they can stop scrabbling
around in the dirt and can start
contributing their brain power to the
collective human Enterprise how about we
make that a bloody priority and remember
other than that while we're doing that
we could we make some real advances on
the environment front because as soon as
they're rich enough to care they'll
start caring and that's I mean even
China is greener than it was 20 years
ago you know that and it's partly
because as China has gotten rich people
have started to care a little bit about
their local environment and we can
really you know places like India are
almost at that threshold now where
they're going to start to really care
and so and the story could be instead of
oh my God it's an apocalyptic Nightmare
and everyone's going to die and we
should only have 500 million people on
the planet and I don't know how the hell
we're going to get rid of the other 7.5
billion but we'll figure out some way we
could say no you know more people like
musk has been saying more people the
better because we can convert we can
convert all that to brain power and if
we were ethical and we had a clue we
could have a future that everybody could
be proud of where no one is starving
where there's a world of abundance where
everybody has opportunity and that would
be a lot better than this bloody
apocalyptic nightmare that justifies
increasing top 10 down tyrannical
pressure it's not a good idea and and
the energy has to be one of those most
fundamental building blocks and I I'm
completely on board with that because as
I say energy realism is energy humanism
we have to be realistic about the limits
of this the these Renewables right and
um my friend Jesse Oswell I mentioned
before he said
um just because he says wind and solar
may be renewable they are not green and
I think that's a just a great a great
way to think about them yes they're
renewable but just because the renewable
doesn't mean they're green what an
example I I you know I could pound the
table on this one Jordan because it does
just get me riled up please do
I was in Wisconsin I had an event at the
University of Wisconsin Oshkosh a few
weeks ago and I flew into Milwaukee and
I've been contacted people from rural
America contact me all the time and
asking me to you know help them find a
lawyer help them you know publicize
their you know their fight against their
renewable project well John uh uh John
Barnes is a resident of Christiana
Wisconsin a little town of 1800 it's
about an hour west of Milwaukee so I got
the rental car I drove straight there I
met him I'm at the Town Town supervisor
Mark cook
um and another one and a woman who was
there whose Name Escapes me at the
moment they're fighting a project that
would cover get this
seven square miles of their little
farming Community it's a farming
community of 1800 would cover some of
the best Farmland in all of Wisconsin
with solar panels
some of the best Farmland in Wisconsin
some of the best Farmland in the world
and these local people are saying we
don't want this and yet it's in venergy
this privately owned
renewable company out of Chicago that is
going to develop the project and then
flip it to uh local uh local utilities
circumventing Wisconsin state law but it
screws that farming Community I mean
just screws them and it's and who's
speaking up for them no one you know
winning solar may be renewable they are
not green why in the world would we be
covering Prime Farmland with solar
panels the answer is very simple it's
the climatism and the investment tax
credit you and you yeah you put you put
those you put those two together right
this renewable energy fetishism which is
I think the right word right description
with these incredibly lucrative tax
credits which for solar amount to like
30 percent of all the layout the initial
Capital cost of the project it's
incredibly profitable for these uh
renewable energy developers to do these
projects and so you know oh food you
know with fiber you know Farmers we
don't care about that we're here to make
money and these are little you know not
Little Farms but they're growing corn
and soybeans they're you know they're
they're they're rural Farmers they're
just getting by and yet they're just
gonna get screwed by these kinds of
projects where's the New York Times
where's the New York Times why is it why
is the Washington Post report hands why
is it in in NPR why aren't they
reporting on this because they don't
care
so you said something interesting that
solar and wind are renewable but you
know I don't think that's true exactly
let me say what I mean by that the sun
and the wind are renewable
but that doesn't mean that solar and
wind power are renewable those aren't
the same thing and and the reason the
reason I'm saying that is because the
lifespan of solar panels isn't very long
and the lifespan of wind generators
isn't very long and so they're not
renewable at all because once they
exhaust themselves they have to be
scrapped and destroyed and then they
they have to be rebuilt so I don't
understand what's renewable about that
at all like if if we were growing solar
solar panels in the field that would be
a different thing but we're not wood is
renewable because wood will grow but
like and I I don't know exactly what
happened to Siemens I haven't been
following that story close enough to
know but the Siemens manufacturing
company and they've taken a huge stock
hit because of this said that their
solar or their Wind Mill generating
systems are much more problematic than
they had originally thought what did
they mean by that like what what exactly
is the problem do you know the problem
on that front what are they run run into
right I I don't know exactly I haven't
looked in into that specifically but
here's my theory and let's go back to
physics and and fluid fluid mechanics
the bets limit is what determines the
amount of energy that you can harness
from the diffused energy in the wind
right it's it's like a water a water and
wind I think in many ways so I
understand an amount of physicist but
they function in many of the same ways
right you there's a limited amount of
power that you can harness from this
diffused source of energy I think they
just got to a point where they made the
system the machines got so big that the
the forces on them are effectively
tearing the machines apart right that
they couldn't the forces the torque the
forces that they're trying to do with in
these gearboxes which are incredibly
complex machines that these you know the
stresses were just too great right that
they made them too big but the
variability too right I mean those
bloody wind uh Mills they have to they
have to operate
from conditions of like zero wind
whatsoever which isn't a problem too
like to like Gale level Gale level
storms and that that's a tremendous
engineering challenge especially and
you're also putting them in the bloody
salt water out in the middle of the
ocean right which is just Madness by the
way you know that you're gonna put them
out there any put anything in salt water
it's going to cost you two or three
times more than putting it on land so I
think this is about basic physics and
they're getting to the limits of the
bets limit right and you have these
blades that are 80 meters long and
you've got to manufacture those and
that's another thing and then when
they're done you you can't you have to
landfill them right there's no way to
recycle them but I want to take it a
little bit different direction Jordan
because it's not just about the machines
and how they're built it's the supply
chains and this is the other part that
is not getting the kind of attention
that it deserves and I've written about
this on my sub stack that these Supply
chains for alt energy are almost all
dependent on China let's look at
electric vehicles why do you think Elon
Musk is building his next gigafactory
I'm in Austin they just built one here
it's a massive factory I just flew in
the other the other night from Miami and
we flew over it it's a massive bet on a
few very specific Commodities Cobalt
lithium uh neodymium neodymium iron
Boron magnets
dysprosium and terbium to name a few
manganu some cute a few others copper
obviously so what's the problem there
well the Chinese control the market for
90 of the global market for neodymium
iron Boron magnets which are the key uh
uh element in the EV Drive Motors right
nearly all the electric vehicles being
produced today use this type of magnet
so other countries can make those
magnets but who controls the terbium and
the dysprosium two other Rare Earth
neodymium turbium and dysprosium are all
rare Earth elements
China controls 100 of the terbium and
dysprosium markets those are the
critical things that are used to dope
the magnets that are put into those EVS
so they can function at high temperature
so it's not but okay so let's go beyond
the magnets which are needed as well in
wind turbines in offshore wind turbines
in particular but the new generation of
wind turbines need these same magnets
and not just a few ounces or a few
kilograms talking tons of magnets
China controls the market completely
what about the other things that we need
graphite for Batteries uh copper uh for
the the material intensity of electric
vehicles is far greater than that for
internal combustion engines so who who
where do all these Supply Chains lead to
China I'm not a China Basher China is
going to take care of China but why in
the name of Peter Paul and Mary now
would the United States be to be staking
its future economy on the Chinese Supply
chains it doesn't make any sense
whatsoever I mean and for the U.S to try
and reassure all of those Technologies
including Rare Earth element refining
and and and these and processing uh
copper Mining and processing and we can
talk about uranium as well there are all
these Supply chains that figure into the
big picture here that are just like
there's a lot of hand waving oh we'll
we'll just keep importing it again who
are you where is the strategy here where
is the long-term thinking about our
strategic vulnerabilities and I don't
see any of that and it's very worried
that's the problem with doing things in
an idiot fear-based Panic is that these
are very very complex problems right and
the supply chain problem is an invisible
part of that and if we did repatriate
those industries that you described well
that would mean a lot more minds and it
isn't obvious at all in today's
regulatory environment that that's even
vaguely possible plus it's not like
there's not an environmental cost to
let's say copper mining
so so the the notion that this is
somehow Green in some obvious way is not
it's not attainable notion at all and
then you add that supply chain
vulnerability to that and that that
could be well that's obviously unwise to
say the least
well well and and it applies to solar as
well and this is something else that's
been largely ignored in many cases just
flat swept under the rug is the supply
of polysilicon for solar panels now let
me be clear I have eight and a half
kilowatts of solar panels on the roof of
my house why did I put them on because I
got three different subsidies hello
I'm I'm opposed to energy subsidies
unless I'm getting them Jordan all right
so let's be clear
but am I sure that those solar panels
which are made in Korea don't have any
content that was that came from China no
and when you look at the solar Market in
fact the U.S government just two years
ago issued an advisory saying that uh
the uh about uyghur slave labor in
xinjiang and the content in particular
for polysilicon produced in xinjiang
with uyghur slave labor and and the U.S
government called it genocide now are
these credible are these exactly right I
don't know for sure but this is very
problematic I mean imagine if the oil
and gas industry were in any way
connected to something involving slave
labor I mean it would be front page news
but because the solar industry again
they get a free pass and I just think
that
we live in a world of networks and
that's the part that I think if I was
gonna think about how your your point
about oh these simplistic Notions it
ignores the fact that all of these
systems all the networks that we rely on
are all interrelated and we've we've
forgotten that and particularly when it
comes to the alt energy discussion we've
neglected this the the to understand how
how vulnerable we are how we're how
Reliant we are on foreign suppliers and
that includes enriched uranium but in
particular it includes Rare Earth
elements neodymium iron Boron magnets
polysilicate nearly all of the alt
energy stuff that is being pushed and
being heavily subsidized now through the
inflation reduction act in the tune of
400 billion dollars depends in either
almost completely or in large part on
Chinese Supply chains
yeah well well the thing is is when
it evolves
Accord it's full of a multitude of
checks and balances right there's many
people providing hydrocarbon based
electricity and there's all sorts of
supply chain problems that have been
ironed out and nailed down and had a
certain degree of resilience built into
them over the course of decades
and those are relatively simple
Technologies in some ways as well
and now what we're trying to do is run
in a mad rush because the sky is falling
to replace all that even though we don't
know how and it's absolutely impossible
failing to understand at all the
invisible supply chain complexities
because the people who are putting
forward the policies have never had to
Grapple with anything like that and they
just assume that if you plug an electric
outlet plug into the wall that the
electricity comes out of the wall right
and and further that you know there's
this blind spot here let me focus in on
the U.S electric grid and uh my friend
Emmett penny with grid brief has done a
lot of good reporting on this
um and and across the U.S we've had grid
operators warning of reliability
problems uh pjm New York ISO uh
California obviously has had huge
problems with grid reliability
um uh the the the Miso of the
Midcontinent independent system operator
all have been warning and as well as the
North American Electric reliability
Corporation of reliability problems why
because we're shuttering our coal plants
too fast and instead of having keeping
those coal plants online were the the
push is on for a lot of these utilities
to install Renewables because that's
where the money is you mean the coal
plants for example that the British
government had to reactivate like three
weeks ago because it got so hot the
solar panels wouldn't work you mean
those coal plants it's just very similar
ones yes exactly so I I what but there's
again I think this is a lack of
Forward Thinking and a lack of
accountability and then I saw it here in
Texas right with the ercot blackouts in
February of 2021 there was this idea oh
well the market failed well who made the
market well well the legislature well
who's in the legislature a bunch of
lawyers well they don't know what the
they don't know how the electric grid
Works they like the idea of the market
and so they said well we're going to
make a market it's going to be great
well who who was responsible well no one
was responsible and that's what we're
seeing now when it comes to these bigger
threats to the reliability of the U.S
grid is everyone's looking around well
who's responsible for reliability uh no
one well that kind of a problem so I
think it's you know I think we've talked
around a lot of big issues here but to
me the one the more when it comes down
to it the US in general and I think the
West in general when it comes to uh the
alt energy push with climatism renewable
energy fetishism it's this narrow focus
on this idea of CO2 is the only issue no
it is a concern it is not our only
concern we have to be concerned about
reliability affordability resilience
these are the key things because one of
the key things that really brought this
home to me and really motivated the work
that I'm doing on this documentary that
I'm working on with my colleague Tyson
Culver
it's one thing to talk about at blackout
it's another thing to to be blacked out
and it really once that happened I
realized well wait a damn minute
if this can happen in Texas the energy
capital of the world what is going on
here and so that led us into this deep
dive for this our new our new
documentary when is that coming out
it'll be out this fall
um we haven't made the announcement yet
but it's uh uh juice power politics and
the grid and uh and that comes out just
before that comes out why don't we do
another uh podcast and you can provide
us with some video footage as well that
we could incorporate into the podcast to
advertise it in some more in some if in
a manner that is as effective as I can
manage because well issue you know in
this this Arc Enterprise we have six
domains of of focus let's say and what
and one is energy and one isn't in one
is environment there's four others yeah
but right we we understand I think as
much as we possibly can that the issue
here as you pointed out is affordability
let's say in reliability and we we want
to take those words apart momentarily
maybe we can do that close this program
I'm off affordability okay that means
poor people don't die
right right that's what affordability
means it doesn't mean that you know
reasonably well-off people can save a
few dollars on their energy bill because
the people who are most hit hardest by
far by any increase in energy costs are
the people who are barely clinging to
the bottom of the economic hierarchy and
there's billions of people like that and
they can easily be knocked back down
into absolute privation and this idiot
moralizing in the west is exactly doing
that and it's hurting poor people like
mad in in the west as well so it's not
just in the developing world right and
reliability it's like well
reliability means that
your food doesn't rot in your
refrigerator how about that or in the
supermarkets right and reliability means
that your power is there when you're on
the bloody operating room table and you
need everything to work a hundred
percent of the time which is what we've
managed right we have this miraculous
bloody industrial state where people are
working flat out 100 of the time
to make sure everything works one
hundred percent of the time and we've
managed that and we're doing everything
we can now to compromise that in the
name of a a false and potentially
genocidal moral virtue it's absolutely
appalling there's a you said a lot there
um I'll reply this way which is if your
energy isn't reliable it's not
affordable
and that is the key right here right
right
um yeah when you talked about those
countries that are turning to the mafia
so to speak to right to supply backup
energy well obviously that's going to
happen everybody will have a bloody
diesel generator in the backyard if we
make the grid unreliable and I don't
think that'll be that good for the
planet well and so you know to build on
that point if your electricity isn't
reliable it's not affordable so that's
what I saw in Lebanon with the generator
Mafia where the grid the grid fails
every day and so people uh they they
have the the generator they have to pay
two electric bills one to edl
electricity and one to the generator
Mafia in some cases they're the almost
the same cost right or look at here here
in the US what's been one of the best
stocks in the United States over the
last few years Generac
the company that built standby
generators right well why is their stock
booming because everyone looks at the
grid and that we're seeing increasing
numbers of blackouts across the country
so people are acting in a rational way
and they're buying generacs well who can
afford generacs it's the same people who
can afford electric vehicles the average
household income for the average Generac
buyer is around 130 140 000 that's twice
the U.S average so here people who are
you know I'm do okay I'm not rich men
but you know if I wanted a Generac I
could afford one I suppose but if your
electricity isn't reliable then it's not
affordable and if it's not reliable you
buy a Generac because you know that it's
going to go off so I've seen it myself
after a hurricane in Louisiana people
like get a small generator and they're
putting gasoline in it because they
can't you know they're we met one guy at
the gas station because he's buying
gasoline to his mom can sleep at night
with an air conditioner right in Houma
Louisiana we talked to this guy so so if
it's not reliable you're going to have
to spend enormous amounts of money to
make it reliable so these things go hand
in hand but I'm so pleased that you know
I was honored flattered to be asked to
you know participate in in the arc
project because electricity is
fundamental and it is a humanist it is a
humanist standpoint to say this is the
critical this is the critical form of
energy that We crave as humans and it's
critical because it makes us more human
electricity is our bodies are electric
where our entire systems are electric
and the creation of the electric grid is
one of the greatest engineering Feats in
human history and it has changed
Humanity like no other form of energy
ever has and if we're going to be
humanist and I will stand on that Pulpit
all day long for going to be humanists
we need to bring more electricity to
more people and in particular to women
and girls because that they're half
they're they're half of humanity and
electricity is an excellent place to end
absolutely man absolutely there is no
bloody way that you can be pro-poor and
you know of the often the most
vulnerable people on the poor front are
obviously women and children there is no
way you can be pro-poor and anti-energy
those two things do not go together not
in the least so yeah yeah it's
unconscionable and one of the things we
really do want to do with the ark and
we're very happy to have you on board
and to have your help on in this regard
is to push constantly to drive Energy
prices down and to climb up that
hierarchy we talk about right from from
biodegradable fools food fuel sources to
Coal to hydrocarbons past hydrocarbons
hopefully up into nuclear with
Renewables in there wherever they can
actually be wherever they can pull their
own goddamn economic weight without a
variety of Market distorting idiot
subsidies that that are that are causing
all sorts of counterproductive activity
so anyways good talking to you Amen to
that one Jordan all right all right so
all right so good talking to you and to
everyone watching and listening thank
you for your time and attention these
things especially for you young people
who are listening you know you guys got
to think this through because this is
the world that's being created now and
you could have a world of you know
continual abundance and reliability
which is kind of what we've had for the
last 50 years miraculously enough or you
could wander down this demented
pseudomoral route and break everything
while making the planet worse and those
are basically the options that are open
to you and so you know it was good to
talk to Robert today he's got some
intelligent things to say on the energy
and environment front and as a man who's
also concerned with environmental
considerations and so you know it's good
to think this through and to issue the
cheap moralizing and to work
forward into a future where we are doing
what we can to supply energy to poor
people because that's the best possible
thing we could manage at least on the
Practical front so thank you very much
for talking to me today sir let's have
another podcast when you get this
documentary up and ready that would be a
very good thing we'll see you in London
at the end of October obviously I'm
looking forward to reading your report
the one that's been uh commissioned for
the for the alliance for responsible
citizenship and so until then uh we'll
turn now over to the Daily wire side I'm
going to talk to Robert for another half
an hour a little bit about so you know a
little more personal issues I'm
interested in how his
his uh calling to the energy environment
Nexus came about and and to delve a
little bit more into
um his motivations for devoting his life
to that so join us on the daily wire
plus front if you're inclined uh the
folks there could use the support
anyways at the moment especially because
we're under you know pretty heavy
assault by the YouTube types at the
moment so thanks invisible YouTube
background sensors you bet Robert thank
you very much thanks thanks a lot Jordan
it was a pro it was a privilege
[Music]
thank you